and re dke is going to wait with
it th up m center it's picked up by petta petta
with a shot and he off the P ring in good settle
down the bouncing Puck quickly turnovers and Puck
management issues carbur has talked about many
many times and on the first shift lovsky off the
boards try to get it in front comes the line it's
over the head of mantis and TJ oosi will race down
the wing Oshi sends it across and shot by mcel sto
by Allen as mat jumps up at set of rice tries to
catch the puck misses it and that creates that
scoring chance new Hook is out of the box mantha
puts it off the outside of the post triy to patch
Allen moving there didn't work though new hook to
Carlson Carlson for Backstrom goes down low ket's
off waiting throws it across all in the save back
from CHS out it CHS at it as well he's knocked
down he's got the puck underneath his feet now
it comes Lo with a great chance at the side of
the neck but can't jam it home rebound for Monahan
up no there G it away tokin Alexander oetkin down
the wing man going to that the F great by vkin
comes down the ice and everyone's thinking wow
he's going to rip this thing and a good slide
quick Suzuki takes him in the corner watched by
Van re DK Suzuki for Monahan at his reach swiped
Away by keer Coffield the Manon shoots car the
save Coffield chipped it for Anderson V rdik
knocked it around the wing CAU the for Suzuki
shot scores and KS it in Howard play goal and the
Canadians strike [Music] first here's the problem
a poor clear by Van rdik you've got to get that
thing hard and up high it's a very weak clear it
never gets out of the zone and then Suzuki to
Monahan he's sitting right in the doorstep all
he has to do is open up the heel to the toe of
the stick and let the puck redirect to the net
he's going to get his second goal a power play
goal and the Montreal Canadians use their power
play new hook will take the draw
against ketov and ketov will slide
it back sandine over to Carlson
up on the wing at oi will angle it
in new hook one the draw Anderson St up with a
shot Pi up by keer where you're going off the
draws and watch this one here the Washington
Capitals win it but they don't get to the puck
Carlson kind of loses it it comes through and
Anderson the right hand shot I've had many a
centerman come up to me right before a
face off and go look it I'm struggling
tonight I'm just going to scramble this so be
ready and that's okay every night's going to
be perfect Here Comes one ahead driving
the net throws an aan gallager Bings it
[Music]
home first of the year for Gallagher two nothing
Montreal the first one on the power play get the
puck to the outside Monahan who's not a quick
skater but just keeps his feet moving and he
just kind of gets to the net and as he gets to
the net he's just laying it into the traffic
area and there you see van R van reinik getting
on the wrong side of Pearson and I was kind of
worried Pearson was going to get a shot at this
Puck and that out of nowhere comes number 11 and
ketov who's the down low centerman is not in the
right spot either look at kets off I mean already
on back tell was checking him for c will bring it
in this time he get C in with a shot oh that was
a big save by put it on the tape and Wilson play
it across as Carlson gets it up to avkin Alexander
oetkin pies the shot vkin shoots made byen Hill
hold on barar knocked down by m coming up here
to M sh towards an N block P's got it all in the
save is a unique and very special player guys all
right well here we go with a minute left in the
power play to start the third with maon still in
the box 200 ft from your new hook to tiip it by
Carlson e Anderson sh be St by keer trying to go
after it power play comes to an end and re throws
it in the slot tipped across Oh shot the off the
crossb now now a chance for sandine shooting
it's block for Coffield off for Nick Suzuki
s c taken away and Chris Nets off will lead the
rush for Washington Beck Valenstein on the wing
tring the n Save By strong drops shoots and this
quickle and Allen to get the strong there o get
up with it Alexander Center strong scores Dylan
stro gets the capitals on the board [Applause]
when you have an opportunity to put your heels and
your boots on the throat of your opponent and for
the monal Canadians two failed five on three power
plays oetkin shoots this one stro almost buries
this on the short side and then a sloppy play
from mat and oetkin who I mentioned before is a
lot better passer than people give him credit for
Phillips knocks it down to oetkin oetkin slides
it through the skates of kovich to stro and it's
nothing but net and now we have a 2-1 hockey game
with 835 to go they'll get it ahead for McMichael
oi out of the way mcel knocks it down centered in
front and Allen will block it K Ring's back at
the point holds it in play in m m with a Chance
Coffield de mat maton looks around played it off
brick Suzuki the C oh got a piece of it pass over
to new Hook New hook tried to get it towards the
go that was Carlson goes after it tipped Away by
PS and all over place no one can get a stick on
an R sweer stro backs up in the zone Zone he'll
play it off for rkin up to Center to Carlson watch
by ol and now it's Chris Nets off that'll bring it
in there goes keer the net is empty for Washington
Chris off k stro firus at home is second and the
nine and the capitals have tied it a two with two
minutes to go it just always seems to come back
to haunt you and that's exactly what's happened
here with two minutes to go who Nets off's going
to come around the net Yoshi goes to the net
Harvey perard does not pick up strome coming
down the outside right there you can see he's late
looking over to pick him up Harris takes him wide
Around the Net across the front and very similar
to the place he was on the first goal on the pass
from oetkin on hand one the draw Suzuki to M at
the point he'll get it in deep on aan trying to
get to it Oshi after it Suzuki can't get it to the
goal and this game will go to [Applause] overtime
right there stres going to the bench there comes
oetkin catches both of them and in that Gap Suzuki
PS Caufield a few steps Over The Line in motion
he's got s sandine beat and on the short side he
beats keer beautiful snap shot and although
they dropped two goals the third period late
they find a way to get the point back gy come
back after those two goals for the Montreal
Canadians and their star players get it done mat
is in to Suzuki to Coffield and that's a goal
scores goal right there even a leg kick involved
there bks throw looking for the hatrick tonight
Allen can't slow it down back
behind the neet mat up toward
Suzuki cotfield [Applause]
shooting oh cotfield overtime
[Music] [Applause]
winner